début mars les députés reprendront leurs
débats très houleux sur le projet de loi
concernant les droits d'auteur sur
internet en décembre dernier l'assemblée
avait créé la surprise en même temps un
amendement légalisant le téléchargement
pour les particuliers en contrepartie du
paiement d'un forfait mensuel c'est ce
qu'on appelle le peer-to-peer un échange
de fichiers deux films ou de musique
entre internautes
c'est le dossier de cette édition il est
signé adèle mostefa eric de l'agneau à
la location 21 décembre dernier peu
avant minuit un petit séisme secoue
l'assemblée nationale
nos enfants deviennent des pirates et d
link ainsi jane par la surprise générale
il est député de gauche s'allie à des
députés de droite
alors on va pas se lancer à la figure de
la course à l'échalote dupuis
réactionnelle des débats techniques
parfois surréalistes sable les bronzés 3
où il ya les drones et pas droit la
réponse est non au final deux
amendements votés qui reviennent à
légaliser le piratage sur internet c'est
absolument ingérable
à l'origine de ce bug parlementaire une
pratique interdite que l'on appelle le
peer to peer
parmi les dix millions de foyers abonnés
internet un adepte du peer to peer
il enregistre ses dvd ou cd sur son
ordinateur
ensuite grâce à un logiciel téléchargé
gratuitement sur internet
n'importe qui peut venir les récupérer
dans son ordinateur
al'inverse lui-même pioche des films et
des chansons chez d'autres internautes
quelques secondes après il peut les
écouter gratuitement et sans scrupules
comme la plupart des habitués du peer to
peer
plus impression de m'ouvrir à beaucoup
de sons et beaucoup de d'image auquel
finalement j'aurais pas accès parce que
moi c'est une histoire de d'argent
toujours donc
donc je me considère pas comme un
délinquant à travers la planète des
millions de films et de chansons sont
ainsi partager gratuitement une caverne
d'ali baba au nez et à la barbe des
industries de la musique et du cinéma
cette pratique est largement répandue
alors pourquoi ne pas légaliser en
échange d'une taxe
julien d'oignons de l'association que
choisir défend cette idée
ça s'appelle la licence globale et ce
serait un forfait de 7 euros par mois
payée par les internautes
c'est un revenu complémentaire pour les
artistes parce que les échanges sont
massifs parce qu'il est impossible de
les éradiquer
à moins d' envoyer tout le monde en
prison ou de flics et l'internet
ce qui n'est pas raisonnable cette idée
de licence globale a provoqué un tollé
chez de nombreux auteurs pour jean
jacques beineix télécharger tout ce
qu'on veut pour cet euro c'est ouvrir la
porte à tous les abus
je vais payer une licence par la licence
iv la licence 5 et ça va me donner le
droit d'aller dans toutes les caves
je peux boire du pinard autant que je
veux et puis je vais demander aussi
notre truc je vais aller dans les
supermarchés et puis je vais remplir mon
caddie autant que je veux même
indignation dans le milieu de la musique
avec la licence globale
ce producteur indépendant pensent qu'ils
perdraient ses revenus actuels et qu'il
ne pourrait plus produire des artistes
comme corneille
pourquoi aller acheter de la musique sur
des sites actuellement payant qui
propose des téléchargements pourquoi
aller acheter de la musique sur des
disques alors que l'on peut avoir
selon ceux qui la propose l'ensemble de
la musique du monde d'hier d'aujourd'hui
de demain du cinéma d'hier d'aujourd'hui
et de demain pour 7 euros par mois c'est
ridicule le vote du projet de loi aurait
dû être une formalité
en quelques semaines c'est devenu un
vaste débat de société sur fond de
luttes acharnées entre lobby la reprise
des travaux parlementaires sera suivie
avec beaucoup plus d'attention qu'en
décembre dernier
chacun sait que le résultat peut être
lourd de conséquences et le piratage